foreign
here we are if you remember back in the
rage Moments video I did mention
something about another Showcase of
Power video and I'm here to keep giving
you exactly what you want luckily for me
2022 has had a lot of these moments that
I can show you I mean we've got a lot of
hype shows delivering and while we can
stay put and wait for more in the coming
year or so why keep ourselves waiting as
we look towards the end of the year
let's celebrate some of the most
impactful and astonishing Showcases of
power we've got from 2022's anime let's
start with a fight that birthed the meme
Sid vs Xenon
[Music]
I didn't read that far into Eminence and
Shadow before the anime so little did I
know that such a fight in the middle of
a season would leave a cultural
footprint of sorts on the community as
minor as it is we do have people riding
along with the I am Atomic thing for a
short while so that is something given
the type of show Eminence in Shadow is I
fully expected something to come up like
this sooner or later despite the premise
of Sid preferring to stay in the
background and such we all knew it was
going to come to this Sunday so when it
happened it felt pretty cool actually
it's been a good while since we've had
some ham-fisted over-the-top destruction
in a toony light novel adaptation and
it's fun to see the brooding protagonist
save the day once again all while
muttering some juvenile yes super cool
boasts and finishing with the total show
of dominance Xenon stood no chance and
we ended up with a minor me so it's a
win-win
feels good to see an overconfident
character taken down a peg isn't it
thanks to letter for this next moment
[Music]
we knew it was coming anyone watching
the first episode of witch from Mercury
knew it was coming but that doesn't take
away from the awesomeness of seeing the
Brash and arrogant gowell get humbled in
the face of a jewel he thought he could
sleep walk through well he either
overestimated his skills or he
underestimated his opponent because he
sure didn't seem like the top duelist
given the flow of the jewel itself turns
out the aerial has way more tricks up
its sleeve than Google gave it credit
for and he pays for that big time the
duel ended up being nothing more than an
extended squash as it sees the dilanza
get completely wrecked against all
expectations it was quite the promising
debut for suleta and the show we get to
see more amazing Jewels down the line
but this is a quick showcase that amazed
both characters in universe and a lot of
Gundam fans eagerly awaiting this show
foreign
[Music]
if these Showcases of power have you
rearing for more may I interest you in
today's sponsor honkai impact third I'm
pretty sure honkite impact needs little
introduction to a lot of you with it
being one of the best and most popular
action RPGs on mobile phones out there
throughout the years honkai impact has
remained strong and this latest update
is set to push the already immersive law
and story to new heights as we get to
learn more about the true nature of
honkite and project stigma make way for
the new character I Hyperion is all
grown up and she's ready to take to the
battle with a chakram I play as a ranged
character who specializes in chaining
attacks and complimenting her will be
new weapons like the super cool looking
Rudder in dream these special effects
look nothing short of stunning to
commemorate this character release
honkai impact will also be launching a
new event the honkai Salvation log with
different iTunes you can take on the
challenge and unlock this beautiful
outfit for midnight absinthe but the fun
doesn't stop there in addition to
midnight Spina astira is also getting a
brand new look but that's not all this
next version will also feature an event
to get the her shirt of thunder the
character cards were made so now's the
best time to start downloading honkai
impact third once you get the game you
can also redeem the code to get awesome
rewards 30 crystals almost 3 000
asteroid and a way to try out Hershey of
Thunder through a demo trial card you
can find the link in the description to
download the game the fun never ends in
honkite in fact three it's about time
that you join in on The Fray back to the
Show with Adam Smasher versus David
how about a villainous example to spice
things up now Adam Smasher has been a
long time favorite among cyberpunk fans
but said fans also can't help but think
that he got the short end of the stick
thankfully cyberpunk Edge Runners is
here to fix that and what we got is this
climactic fight between David and Adam
Smasher true David's on his last legs at
the time of this showdown I mean I don't
even think he thought he would win this
fight yeah even with all the
enhancements and the power-ups he'd just
gotten there's just no way he would
feasibly be able to defeat Adam Smasher
and even if he somehow did in a
miraculous twist there's a fake worse
than death awaiting him on another note
that doesn't take away from how strong
Adam Smasher is David at this point
barely even put up a fight as he gets
obliterated completely by Adam Smasher
you see that's how you build up a
villain that way when said villain gets
beaten eventually there could be a lot
of hype surrounding the one who comes
out with the win it's a writing
technique that will be used for the next
entry too
[Music]
[Applause]
Boss versus Oken is a fight to remember
ranking of Kings has been regarded as
one of the best anime to come out of
2022 period and how about showing off
the fight between boss and okin one of
the best moments the series gave us it
plays things out the standard build up
and defeat wave first we get to see
Oaken show off the power of His
immortality in spite of being
outnumbered by all those Master
combatants none can stand up to the
power of okin and his Unstoppable
regeneration but then comes boss after
building up okin the show then builds up
boss by having him absolutely defeat
okin in a one-sided Showdown no
questions asked it's over boss
completely dominated the fight and in
case you're wondering about oaken's
immortality well it turns out the King
has just the right solution for that
it's not a battle that showcases
explosive techniques or super speed or
anything like that but it sure is a huge
huge Showcase of power on the part of
Boss Leo vs generals is also an off
overlooked one
I say the latest statement knowing that
not a lot of people watched I'm quitting
heroing that's to be expected given how
the series at first glance does seem to
be one of those Niche light novel
adaptations starring what looks to be a
stock light novel hero you know the
Kirito type if you will in a fantasy
world it's got its moments however and I
think the premise is unique and has ever
put into it it's also got a Nifty Flex
moment where Leo shows off why he's
someone who once defeated the entire
demon Army before he goes up against the
four generals and effortlessly shows how
above all of them he is in the process
he does shift into a more villainous
Persona giving credence to the humans
who feared him it's not surprising for
anyone to root for the generals after
seeing how Leo easily handles them with
that kind of attitude to boot but it's a
good moment overall both in how
awesomely Leo overcomes all of his
opponents and giving a notable character
shift for a protagonist
[Music]
foreign
rock is an amazing moment and it's a
great Showcase of power
[Music]
the decisive battle against kaido took
everyone through a whirlwind of emotions
didn't it for such an anticipated
Showdown that was years in the making it
sure made the weight worth it the battle
which spanned for a lot of episodes gave
us some of the best animation one piece
has had in a while and given how the
modern episodes have stepped up in that
department for this fight to stand out
is really something special everything
looked better when Luffy busts out his
Red Rock against kaido it truly felt
like the culmination of the journey and
the anime team just had to throw all
those flashbacks at us to remind us of
the road our hero had passed through to
get to this point that Red Rock does
feel like the climax of The Journey and
it's those feelings that fueled him to
finally take the fight to both big mom
and kaido and the results they were
glorious for the longest time kaido
seems so infallible but with the Red
Rock things have started looking out for
the heroes for good
[Music]
we then move on to the next epic
Showcase of power shigaraki's Awakening
shigaraki pre-season 6 is already bad
news we've seen what he can do with his
powers and know how overpowered it has
the potential to be but to see a
demonstrated firsthand in this way
absolutely amazing and scary to wit this
guy went from decaying body parts to
completely wrecking a city with his
improved Powers such as the true
destructive potential of his Quirk and
seeing even heroes fall to his might
will be enough to induce despair into
anyone a whole minute showcasing the
destruction is more than enough to evoke
memories of pain wrecking gonoha back in
Naruto Shippuden I personally enjoy the
tone switch that my hero Academia pulled
here the first parts are quite easy
going despite all the changes you always
feel that there's no real threat present
it feels like the story of deku's growth
and all might's presence bringing hope
to everyone but now it's gone and it's
like the villains are the ones being
overpowered really gives us a completely
different outlook on the series it's now
everyone's struggle against an
Unstoppable God of destruction and with
protagonist plot armor being ripped off
one by one I'm loving every minute of it
foreign
as we move towards the end of the list
Feast your eyes on the rumbling
ever wondered what it's like being face
to face with the greatest cataclysm set
forth to destroy the world there's a
very special type of fear that can only
be evoked by such images of hopelessness
and that's the very feeling that the
rumbling embodies Titans marching across
the world laying waste to everything and
not even being grazed by conventional
Weaponry that's the pride of humanity
now that that's true fear this is even
more harrowing than how Attack on Titan
opened the first on-screen appearance of
the Titans a decade ago doesn't even
hold a candle to this and the rumbling
that caps off the fourth season's second
part is a true Testament to the
uncontrollable power that Aaron now
holds there's no stopping the horde of
Titans there's no running away from them
and how are you supposed to fight
against such an unbeatable wave the
rumbling manages to evoke the Hopeless
and scary implications that the first
part of the series was so Rife with it's
a primal fear that was lost during the
Epic action thanks to the main
characters but it's back now it's even
stronger than ever
foreign
[Music]
it's finally here after ages of
anticipation we finally get to see
yamamoto's Bankai animated in what many
consider to be the best episode of
Bleach Thousand-Year blood Wars first
course so far and the Bankai is exactly
what everyone expects a monstrous Force
fit to be wielded by the goatee's
strongest Captain now as a manga reader
I'm very pleased with the additions the
anime team put in expanding the fight in
all early on however the meat of the
fight is just something we've seen from
The Source material yamamoto's Bankai
and its multiple forms that could be
Bank eyes of their own to be honest I'm
not sure which is the most awesome
amongst the four modes they all look so
great in their own ways you are all the
person supposed to be you are look
completely like a paid actor in a
Yamamoto highlight reel one where the
anime team managed to flex their
animation skills and show off how well
they do their impact frames a high
package like this is simply the perfect
way for Yamamoto to shine brightest
before exiting the stage
foreign
for me one of the show's most powerful
Showcases of power didn't come from an
actual fight you see you're going to
chainsaw man expecting some major flexes
and insane bloodbaths in the fight and
you'd be correct however have you seen
someone exude so much control and
presence over a situation like Maki
might just did in episode nine yeah
control is the right way to put it into
words because makima just showed us her
power and how scary it really can be
when put in the hands of a ruthless
devil like her without even taking part
in the action makima just as easily
causes a massacre slowly and
methodically exploding people to me
that's even scarier and more powerful
than actually getting mutilated in
battle now you agree this episode set up
a lot of things to be skeptical about
for this character and yes I don't want
to spoil things further but let's just
say that there's a lot more to her
character than meets the eye
foreign
Showcases of power from the year 2022
with all the great titles the years
given us I wouldn't be surprised if I
missed something so if you feel there's
something that deserves to be on the
list then don't forget to comment on it
down below and let me know also you can
check out honkite impact third using the
link in the description please stay
tuned as we've got a lot more videos
coming your way only on videotube